c'est maktouf bonjour vous êtes
spécialisé dans la défense des familles
victimes du terrorisme
on l'a dit la situation a évolué en
syrie depuis la profession de washington
en 2018 mais berne reste campé sur ses
positions et souhaite ne rapatrier que
les enfants le djihadiste originaire de
suisse
que peut-il se passer selon vous dans
les prochains jeux m'ont coûté la
situation a toujours été très critique
parce que malheureusement les états
européens en tout cas certains n'ont pas
décidé de prendre leurs responsabilités
en matière de lutte contre le terrorisme
aujourd'hui ces terroristes qui sont
détenus par les kurdes et grâce aux
kurdes d'ailleurs ne peuvent pas rester
indéfiniment de temps que le risque de
fuite d'évasion est plus que probable un
certain nombre de ces djihadistes c'est
déjà évadé rappelons-nous le cas de
péter chérif qu'elle était incarcérée et
est jugée incarcéré et réussi à fuir
aujourd'hui ce que je veux dire c'est
que il y à un risque qui touche la
totalité des pays du monde
du fait de la probabilité extrêmement
importante de fuite de ces terroristes
est de les retrouver un jour ou l'autre
face à nos c'est en réglant les
problèmes et voyons la situation en face
qu'on pourra se prémunir contre
d'éventuels attentats terroristes
la suisse a essayé de régler l'année
dernière un problème par la déchéance de
la nationalité
da de ses ressortissants binational turc
et suisse sauf que malheureusement la
situation juridique n'est pas toujours à
même de répondre à ces situations
c'est pourquoi il faut aller fort
extrêmement important des différents
états pour ensemble trouver une solution
de temps que je voudrais leur rappeler
c'est primordial est su
extrêmement important c'est qu'il s'agit
de ressortissants européens en
l'occurrence nous parlons de citoyens
suisses et au titre de ce passeport de 7
du fait d'être ressortissant de cet état
de droit l'état de droit se doit de les
juger de les rapatrier
même s'il s'agit de criminels justement
les avocats des trois suspects cas
justement les avocats des trois suspects
demandent un procès en suisse pour avoir
droit je cite à un procès équitable et
une défense équitable
tout à fait c'est pourquoi je voulais
rappeler l'appartenance fort
heureusement de notre démocratie
ce qui fait la différence entre nos
états de droit et la barbarie
c'est que nous devons au titre de cet
état de droit offrir à ces criminels un
procès équitable
non pas pour leur confort non pas pour
leur offrir une protection
ils ont fait ce qu'il ya de pire ce que
l'humanité n'a pas vu depuis très
longtemps
écoutez c'est je le rappelais tout à
l'heure je suis avocate de victimes du
terrorisme et beaucoup de ses parents
qui ont perdu leurs enfants dans des
attentats horrible terroriste considère
qu'il kiné de leur droit légitime qu'un
procès puisse se tenir et au delà même
de leurs droits légitimes
je voudrais également dire que les
rapatriés permet de garder une main sur
la traçabilité la possibilité de les
débris fait parce que les débris fait et
comprendre le terrorisme c'est pas moyen
de prévenir contre le terrorisme vous
l'avez dit le débat est donc toujours
d'actualité et notamment concernant le
rapatriement ou non des djihadistes
originaire de france vers l'hexagone
vers quoi est-ce qu'on se dirige du côté
de paris de la france écoutez a priori
la france est en train d'avancer au cas
par cas
ce que je souhaiterais c'est que la
politique français soit beaucoup plus
clair et j'espère avec ce risque
d'évasion qui a débuté d'ailleurs il a
débuté puisque nous avons retrouvé des
terroristes en afrique en libye est donc
dans d'autres pays rejoindre même des
groupes der terroristes comme aqmi où
boko haram
aujourd'hui il y a face à ce risque
une nécessité qui est celle de s'unir en
tant qu'etat européen de tracer une
feuille de route pour lutter contre le
terrorisme et éviter que ces terroristes
puissent ne pas frapper à notre porte
mais arrivé sans prévenir
et malheureusement peut-être commettre
l'irréparable à savoir d'autres
attentats terroristes parce qu'ils sont
animés par cette idéologie mortifère et
c'est plus qu'une qu'une qu'une idée
c'est une obsession poursuit merci les
enseignants maktouf d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
avocate au barreau de paris spécialiste
dans la défense des familles victimes du
terrorisme